alright guys bangbang I've got Josh here
we got a whole bunch of stuff to talk
about so thanks for doing this thanks
for having me man good to see you yeah
for sure for those that don't know you
let's just start background kind of
where you grew up and then we'll get
into the founding story of LOX born in
Cali parents split when I was three
moved to Coney Island Brooklyn which I
consider home and grew up there sort of
a mix between a science nerd and a lover
of all things basketball and hip-hop
went to Cornell graduated went to
Investment Banking wasn't even smart
enough to collect my first year bonus
started locks and man it's almost two
decades so yeah I system yeah so one of
the things is you post music on Twitter
all the time which I appreciate because
I think there's an entire generation of
kids that grew up you know relatively in
the same age group we all listen to
hip-hop everyone loved the NBA
Allen Iverson right there just like this
whole generation and then when you get
in the professional world like nobody
really talks about it but you still post
all the music and everything and it just
like look like that's who he is that's
literally the generation he grew up in
right either that's a nice way of saying
you're old or no it's true it's it's I
actually think for you know what we do
when we do venture capital is is very
akin to trying to find you know the next
new band or artist you're looking on the
outskirts I've always been drawn to both
you know art and music that was slightly
off the beaten path and so my wife is
totally you know casey kasem top 40 you
know all the pop hits and i've always
been drawn towards weirder stuff that
you would never hear on the radio and so
it's the same sort of thing in venture
capital I'm typically never drawn
towards the stuff that everybody else
was focused on I want to understand what
everybody else too focused on so I won't
listen to you know all the top hits in
music but I like the the weirder fringe
stuff and and there's a virtue of that
because when you discover it there's
sort of a you know a future status that
you get when you're like oh I knew this
you know I was listening to this before
everybody else so I think that's sort of
the hit that you know you keep getting
but it happens to be that the music in
my mind is just better the tones the
discordant
it's sort of more emotionally resonant
with my own psychology than you know
beetles pop music how much of that do
you think is like personal preference
right so hey I just tend to like this
type of music versus you actually
actively made a decision to go seek out
maybe music that other people didn't
like I think it was an emotional
resonance so I've always had a chip on
my shoulder you know I was like the
short kid that was the the kid you know
they like get beat up in Coney Island
you know I just sort of always
distrusting my family was split and
broken and so I just always gravitated
towards like darker hip-hop hard heavy
metal in New York hardcore you know and
there's like the this emotional
crescendo you know I love museum fact I
just post on Twitter like I think it was
Deftones and was raging this machine
maybe was helmet you know now I get to
indoctrinate my kids with this which is
really funny now they don't share the
same emotional you know diss coordinates
that I had my whole life was geared
towards making them grow up you know in
a pop music kind of world but I love
when you know it just gets like super
mellow mellow metal and it just explodes
with like rage and emotion so whether
that's a you know crazy riff and heavy
metal or you know just dropping in and
saying beaten hip-hop it's the same sort
of thing
for sure and then obviously you went
into Investment Banking kind of start
your career and at some point you know
you've said a number of times that you
wanted to find that intersection between
science and finance and venture capital
it feels like Wall Street was I want to
say late to the game but but it was
definitely more of a West Coast kind of
Silicon Valley type business and maybe
some in Boston as well what was kind of
the thought process for you guys I know
people probably thought you're crazy to
some degree but kind of what was the
really the genesis of wanting to jump
into a venture well part of it is
probably intellectual EDD I mean the
beautiful thing about venture is you get
to focus on a million different things
and usually it's driven by the brilliant
people who are constantly pursuing
something new and cutting-edge out of
their own either greed or quest for
status or fame or money or whatever it
might be so so that was really the
driving impetus science for me is
interesting because it's the endless
frontier so no matter what we discover
you know
that you expand the circumference of
what's known it just basically also
expands the circumference of what's
unknown as it touches the darkness and
so even the derivation of the word
Locke's Latin for light you know was
looking where other people weren't
looking and shining a spotlight so that
we can try to find interesting things
that we thought the mainstream wasn't
focused on so at the time when we
started lux everybody was focused on
comms an optical networking and those
were the things which were front page
news and had you know dozens of top tier
firms which we could never hope to
compete with and hundreds of also rads
you had all kinds of incubators that
were existing around time for like comms
and e-commerce businesses and all that
would go on you know and like any field
99% of these things would fail 1% would
go on and change the world and make
fortunes a priority very hard to pick
who that would be but we said let's
focus on an area where other people
weren't and we basically looked at the
cascading s-curves throughout the
history of venture capital where every
10 or 15 years some secular wave in a
technology field 1970s pcs nineteen
eighties biotech 90s telecom and TMT and
we said the next wave might be the
physical and material sciences so let's
go to the universities the government
labs the corporate labs where those
breakthroughs were happening it happened
to be at the time mostly because
everybody was focused over here that
most people are not focused on physics
chemistry material science and so that
allowed us to carve out a niche in this
sort of emerging technology and over
time you know the rubric would change
went from nanotech to emerging tech to
you know now people call it deep tech
but it's basically just like hard
science the average entrepreneurs age is
typically you know 25 to 35 as opposed
to like 15 to 25 you typically have to
have a PhD in some of these fields you
know the average starting pay for a
biotech exec is you know an order of
magnitude higher than your traditional
IT exec and one of the really
interesting things I think is that the
range of what we do because it's very
interdisciplinary multi disciplinary
means that we might be working on you
know something for telescopes and
astronomy a one day and then it turns
out that the guy who won a Nobel Prize
for something in taking a technique like
that is creating a new tool to be able
to do real-time imaging inside of cells
in biology and so you're sort of
constantly flipping between these fields
and I just think that it's that these
interspecies between these different
disciplines where the amazing
breakthroughs happen and it's just you
know it's like a smorgasbord of
intellectual
excitement now economically it doesn't
always work but intellectually it's you
know it's endless game for sure and when
you guys started did you or your
partner's did anyone have kind of deep
tech background or science background or
were you guys coming at this and really
having to immerse yourself and learn
from scratch so I had a background a
molecular bio I was a published
scientist doing immunopathology I had
watched a movie quite literally in the
early 90s I was a early teenager called
and a band played on and it had this
huge formative impact on me was about
the AIDS crisis and I was like I'm gonna
go be scientist I'm gonna literally cure
AIDS and this was the naive absurd
thinking I ended up doing my
Westinghouse in a small protein called
uro kinase and how it evolves the
progression of HIV into full-blown AIDS
particularly in children and I just
banged on the door of a scientist in
downstate Brooklyn to let me work in the
lab which I did for four or five years
and it was actually him who turned me on
to finance because we would be spinning
down a centrifuge of blood and he'd be
making tens of thousands of dollars for
trading features and options and I knew
nothing literally nothing he gave me a
Wall Street Journal guide to money and
investing that he I think he got sort of
like a football phone that they used to
give you with Sports Illustrated when
you got your subscription and that was
like my first foray into understanding
markets and I also remember I lost every
dollar I had saved up which is about
like $1,800 over the course of a summer
and a half of working like TGI Fridays
and you know shoveling snow during the
winter and delivering menus and
Sheepshead Bay Brooklyn because I bet it
all on a company called I Omega and I
Omega was like a hard disk drive I think
it might have been involved in fraud but
it was just you know absolute disaster
but anyway so I had a little bit of a
scientific background just more on the
biological science side and Peter was
journalists background coming out of
Syracuse I went to Cornell he was at
Lehman Brothers and Equity Research and
I was at Sally in investment banking we
knew each other through a mutual friend
that I grown up with and yeah then we
started lux and then just surrounded
ourselves with really smart people yeah
one of the concepts that Paul Graham
recently talked about is like this whole
idea of like learning to unlearn and I
think that you guys specifically given
how multidisciplinary the types of
companies you
right it's not like most of these
companies that are on that frontier are
only using one piece of technology many
times it's multiple pieces how do you
actually think about getting up to speed
on a piece of technology or an industry
that either you don't know a lot about
or you just haven't had the time really
to spend to be able to ask the right
questions to diligence the right things
and do you guys do that or do you
actually go to outside sources to help
on that diligence most of it is outside
sources in the forms of both what you
can read you know somebody else is
publishing something synthesizing what
they may know or may have learned and
you know it mean the Internet is amazing
right the ability for you to learn
something today versus you know 20 years
ago was just insane so the synthesis of
what other people are putting together
and you know obviously there's you know
every degree from like deep science
that's being published to journalists to
laypeople that might you know tweet
something and put something on medium
but nobody really has a you know a
monopoly on really interesting insights
and ideas and truths and frameworks so
you know you can get those from anywhere
it sort of gives me information anxiety
which is why I'm constantly reading
every source I can we can talk about
that to just sort of where I read and
what I read and you know in the same way
is looking for bands or music or
startups I think you have to find
information that is off the beaten path
and then the other piece is talking to
people and so over time you build the
network obviously and we went from you
know talking to you know pretty crappy
startups to more serious startups to
Nobel prize-winning scientists and heads
of academic departments and so most of
the time now we're able to triangulate
and understand somebody for real or full
of it and in pretty cutting-edge new
areas you know we could do a six-month
to deep dive and we could have a whole
set of views I mean I'll give you a
perfect example we started up a company
around this crazy thesis that sort of
bordered on science fiction for x-men
which was finding genetic mutants people
that have really rare phenotypes that
exist in the real world and there's some
genetic basis for that and so there were
a whole set of people when I first
started looking at this was there an
opportunity for a new company to focus
on that but I thought were like the
people and over time you triangulate and
you start talking to you know five other
people and then you get some negative
references about this guy and then she's
not really you know legitimate and so
you sort of build your own mosaic of
like whose advice or information on
insights you're going to weight more
heavily in who you think it's just you
know utterly you know full of it
and that takes time you know particular
if you're totally ignorant so most areas
both by preference and almost by
definition we enter with a very high
degree of ignorance and then our job is
to reduce that ignorance get as smart as
we can ultimately develop a confidence
that we think we're smarter than
somebody else because either we found
something that they haven't found yet or
we know more than them and then when we
feel advantaged we write a pretty big
check yeah and I think that you're
really talking about kind of the the
collision of a couple of trends here so
recently I saw on Twitter that you were
talking about this idea that like
science is not consensus driven right
that's not a whole point of science but
then how do you balance that in your
mind with things like content moderation
and censorship where there are accepted
norms there's accepted pieces of
information and sometimes actually the
people who end up having the
breakthrough or coming from a place that
was previously thought to be taboo or
false even and like how do you sift
through that as you're taking all this
input of information and trying to
really kind of come up with a maybe not
a conclusion but actually I got thesis
as to how you think the world will move
in the future so a few different things
so on the sort of institution of science
itself where there's actually a lot of
negative things about the
institutionalization but science is a
process does not depend on a consensus
it just depends on a conjecture there's
evidence you know based on observations
from a hypothesis conjecture and then
you can make a reasonable conclusion
basically tentatively held nobody ever
says with certitude this is what is and
oftentimes the old ideas get replaced by
better explanations or bad explanations
get replaced by good explanations and
that's how science progresses you know I
think it was Linus Pauling I may be
messing up the attribution who said that
science proceeds one funeral at a time
and so a lot of the old guard who gets
famous and you know gets a chaired
Department and has all the postdocs that
want to work for them and gets the fame
and gets the appointments and gets the
board of directors at engineering
companies god famous in many cases for
you know flawed or bad explanations that
were widely accepted until some young
hotshot you know full of piss and
vinegar this is like no I don't think
that's the way it works and then you
know they upturn it and this process for
peace so there's a predictability to the
unpredictability of how science itself
advanced
when attempt when it comes to you know
policy whether it's you know for a city
or for a company or for how somebody
runs their family or the choices that
you make of what you put in your body
you know that that is less about science
itself as a process and more about
prescriptions and advice and risk
management when it comes to you know
sorting through everything that you
might read online and you know
recommendations and you know criticisms
you know that that's just all sort of
analysis based on you know what
everybody's putting out there but but
science itself I feel you know just sort
of absolutist about it is is a process
that is just constantly trying to come
up with better and better questions and
better and better explanations but it's
an endless process because whatever we
hold to be tentatively true today is
very likely to be overturned in you know
some point in the future by somebody
that's just come up with a better
explanation yeah and I guess part of
this is the science community is is
pretty aware of this right as part of
the process they're almost trained and
have the experience and those around
them that have gone through that the
rest of society doesn't have that
mindset right it's kind of like there is
a truth and that truth will forever be
true how when there's things like
coronavirus for example right where at
the time given the information that
somebody has there are certain
conclusions or beliefs that are held
they get either disproven or proven over
time how do we kind of navigate that as
a society understanding that the
majority of people don't have that
scientific type bent or you know thought
process as they're ingesting information
broadly to me this falls under sort of
two pieces one of which is leadership
and there's all kinds of techniques of
leadership and persuasion and the other
one is psychology and network effects
you know why some ideas catch on and
spread just like a contagion and why
they are believed and why you know some
are outright rejected you know so
whether you look at it in coronavirus
which you could say you know we'll have
the post facto explanations of this were
all easy you know Monday morning
quarterbacks and armchair but you know I
consider gates and authority on this not
because he's an expert in infectious
disease but it's a topic that he cares
deeply about and he has said look I
think it was January February he
published in the New England Journal of
Medicine saying this is more serious
than the
and signs are alarming five years ago he
called for you know sort of a
coordinated global effort and making
sure that we had the capacity to deal
with something like this and it sort of
fell on deaf ears or maybe people
thought that he had the money and the
willpower would you know sort of handle
it himself or something but these kinds
of debates
you know they've existed for everything
from global warming and climate change
you know there's core quality scientific
consensus on the one hand there are
actual scientific facts about what's
changing there's other things that you
would say directionally like lend itself
towards a natural decarbonisation of the
economy and you have things like the
vaccine movement and the anti-vaxxers
and so there's clear evidence which
would suggest that there is a prudent
course of action and there's always a
minority or majority of people that will
ignore that evidence and choose not to
take that behavior I am you know
outspoken in my non religiosity I'm an
atheist I don't believe but you know
there are billions of people that
believe in an Invisible Man in the sky
that you know directs things and no
amount of evidence you know to the
contrary or the absence of evidence of a
presence would would swayed them that
has to do with you know early
indoctrination inheritance psychology
you know and leadership and so I think
it's the same thing any any any topic
where you know you can look at something
with an absolute truth and people have
sort of varying opinions is gonna be a
function of you know groupthink
psychology leadership or the absence
thereof yeah I guess going on that
leadership thread for a second there's
probably an overhype narrative that
we've got lots of really really smart
people that are going into fields that
don't produce lots of materials
approximate services or aren't hard
science driven right so it's kind of the
whole like hey everyone's going to build
photo apps why do we keep funding this
stuff there's probably some grain of
truth there but also some exaggeration
how do you think about solving getting
the smartest people in the country from
an education basis into more for
Sciences and more kind of
production type roles rather than either
wealth redistribution or things that are
more nice to haves than need to have
okay so let's think this maybe three
ways one is economic incentives and this
is a raging debate that my wife and I
have the second is the sort of moral
prescription of what people ought to be
doing and then the third is sort of the
unintended consequence and so these will
sound sort of mutually exclusive because
you know like Fitzgerald said the test
of a first-rate intellect is the ability
to opposing ideas and you haven't seen
time still retain the ability of
function so I have opposing ideas about
this so let me give you one idea which
is the moral prescription right we ought
to have more people pursuing more
serious things you know we even talked
about in sort of a you know
self-righteous way that we like to fund
matter that matters and we're not
funding trivial video games but the
reality is a lot of the investment in
what we consider frivolous or trivial
ends up becoming critical I mean there
is no doubt in my mind that the reason
that we are able to do real-time
protocol right now video conferencing is
in part because of you know frivolous
stuff that people did for video gaming
and twitch streaming and all that kind
of stuff that we would you know a mock
and be like oh my god what are these
people doing but you know proverbially
thank god that all the stuff was
invented same thing you know video
compression codecs
you know people wasting away like couch
potatoes on netflix you know it is
enabling this at the moment and a priori
none of that was predicted so I was like
to say that you know the detritus from
one former wave becomes the
combinatorial fraud or for the next and
you know until we look at a post facto
it's not predictable so a lot of the the
the silly seemingly trivial or absurd or
wasteful things that people are doing
today end up being useful later on you
know a few years ago I talked about how
the most dangerous words and markets
often are considered you know this time
is different and I think that the most
valuable words in my markets can be it
will rot our brain because every time
that that phrase was uttered you know if
you look through the decades it
basically precised the next 10 billion
dollar industry so you had rock-and-roll
music literally you know generation of
older parents and this is devil's music
you know Elvis shape and it's shaking
his head
you had the same
with jazz you had it with TV in the 60s
and 70s you had it with online chat
rooms in the 80s and videogames in the
90s and 2000's and so anytime a parent
says it will rot your brain you know you
see it now right my generation of
parents with kids that are sort of
tweens or younger we all lambaste screen
time you know you got to do this digital
detox and you have to be in the moment
and present but again look at our
current absurd situation and these kids
are digital natives they're fluent
they're teaching parents how to connect
you know and I actually think that the
mediums that they used today whether
it's you know tick tock or Marco Polo or
whatever actually very creative artistic
mediums that you know we're gonna
express genius through so that's the
argument for why we ought not try to
redirect and just let the frivolous
happen because the geniuses will end up
repurposing the frivolous for the useful
over time naturally the raging debate
economically that my wife and I have is
I always say you know do we really need
another marketing major you know going
to school taking on debt and just coming
out with no expertise don't we need more
computer scientists and engineers and
people well the market early sort of
sets a price because you're graduating
salary if you were going into nuclear
engineering or you were going into
hardcore material science or you were
going into CRISPR for biotech you know
would be much higher than if you were
coming out with like just a liberal arts
degree or some you know marketing degree
and so you're already sort of a subprime
credit if you're pursuing the latter and
so I've made the argument why not lend
just like we used to you know during the
last housing crisis there was prime
credits based on you know your
likelihood to pay and subprime credits
why not based on the major that you're
electing to choose to pursue have lower
borrowing rates so you might be a better
credit if you were pursuing computer
science over the past 10 years and you
should borrow one or two percent well
that would lower the cost of access of
capital it would increase the number of
people that were potentially applying
for it and over time it would end up
increasing the supply of labor which
would then bring down the price and
wages in the marketplace and so you'd
have a natural sort of you know
filtering function just letting the
market based on salaries dictate where
there was need you know five years ago
four years ago
insane demand for artificial
intelligence researchers you know people
that come out of the nuclear winter and
deep learning accomplish convolutional
neural nets where suddenly the hottest
in demand and somebody that was making
$50,000 or less as a postdoc was
suddenly being offered half a million to
a million dollars at Google and Facebook
and and so that was just insane and it
created a scarcity of Labor which was a
signal to the market and now you know
every computer science program is like
you know flooding the zone with with few
trejo researchers at a time when it will
probably bring down all the wages and
then you know the next area that's
totally scarce will become you know the
hot demand same thing in an area you
know where you're an expert in crypto
right there's any time there's the sort
of information arbitrage and ignorance
and that's reflected in the prices of
wages of Labor I think it's a signal and
so if you want to redirect where useful
resources of humanity goes you know
prices today are still the best way that
we have to signal that to the masses
yeah and make as part of this is how
much of that is driven by the individual
right understanding that like I was joke
when ever I talked to a college kid I
literally say you know why do you want
to go do X and they'll give me some
usually non-financial driven reason and
I say do you know it's that person earns
have you talked to anybody in that
industry and this is a lack of I think
education and information and it's more
of like I want to go do what makes me
happy type situation and so do you think
that that disconnect is when you're
younger they care less about the
financial outcomes and so there might be
some dislocation there or do you think
ultimately it all falls back to the
financial incentives well there's
definitely an ignorance about income I
mean if you know my oldest is my
daughter is ten years old the sorry one
second my oldest of my of my kids ten
years old and you know if I ask for oh
what do you think you know that person
makes or you know no idea you know I
don't know like hundred dollars you know
it's like not quite that absurd but so
there's a general ignorance where it's
just you know what's more interesting
over time of course you have a signal of
like what are other people value it with
their attention and so a lot of people
you know take where I grew up in Coney
Island most people wanted to be ballers
or rappers because that's what was being
celebrated in the community as a culture
you get
what you celebrate you know both in a
local community in a small ethnic or
demographic group and as a country or at
large so if we were to celebrate
engineers and entrepreneurs and people
that were scientists and not you know
just celebrities you would get more of
that and so I think there is a virtue of
a culture celebrating something so as to
give status to it and to elevate it and
and you know you're starting to see that
I think you know whether it's in the
fictional world you know when you had
movies like the Martian you know gravity
or in the real world as you know I'm
very critical about what I considered it
to be the ethics and the mendacity but
Elon Musk is a tremendous boon for the
the an entire generation of people that
look to both the stars and a brighter
future and say I want to be like that
and so to the extent that figures like
him can encourage people to want to
pursue science and engineering it's a
beautiful thing yeah so obviously I want
to spend some time talking about him but
but I guess part of this is you are
probably one of the more outspoken
people who I believe separates what I'll
call the promotion and marketing and
kind of the outward message from the
science that's being done there and just
so people understand I think your
position is a big believer in the
science and kind of the ultimate visions
of those companies but the way it's
being executed is the best way to scrap
it might be there's better ways to do it
is that fair
that's diplomatic I mean I've been
blunter online so let you know let let's
list the things you know sort of
intellectual honesty the things that I
would admire I think the pursuit of
going to another planet you know or to
the moon again is is a brilliant thing
what we will discover and learn as the
sort of entropic exhaust from that that
will be useful for Society will be huge
it gives people both the sense of
purpose and meaning and society
generally needs that so that's a virtue
the talent that has flooded into places
like SpaceX and Tesla and boring and
others are brilliant engineers and
they're motivated by somebody who speaks
to them you know as a as a good leader
of this is a future and I want to take
you there and so I think all of those
very virtuous things I think the design
is brilliant
I think the renderings I think there's
an artistic aesthetic ethos to all the
companies that are quite brilliant and
and a lot of people say well you're
really critical about the stock or the
valuation and I'm actually not so
critical about stock I mean people can
you know it's a free market you can own
something you make money or lose it if
it goes up or down and if you think it's
fairly valued or undervalued my main
criticism is the what again what I would
call the mendacity the relationship with
the truth this is something that you
know people can't understand this why do
you hate you I don't hate you on it's
not a personal thing it's it's a feeling
that there's a knowing manipulation of
the masses in the same way that I would
look at a Sunday preacher and there are
some people that would look at a Joel
Osteen or a creflo dollar or Jim Baker
back in the day and say this guy is
amazing and I'd be sitting there being
like are you serious like you don't see
this guy is literally trying to fleece
you for your money and bullshitting you
and so there's elements of that where I
understand why it has to be done the
show has to go on and the showman must
do sort of like the Simpsons manarola
monorail man to get people to part with
their money but I also truly believe if
you ran the counterfactual that he would
have absolutely been able to raise tens
of billions of dollars necessary in a
loss-making enterprise and do it
honestly by saying we are going to do
some of the most ambitious thing that
man's I've ever seen and we're going to
lose money for a really long time and if
you don't want to be part of that
journey you should not invest but if you
do you know I promise it's gonna be a
wild ride
people would part with their cash they'd
be part of it and maybe some people have
already rationalized that that's what it
is but when you're saying like we're
gonna be cashflow positive and we're
profitable and you're playing with the
numbers and you're trying to induce you
know certain institutional investors and
retirement money when the stocks going
up and everybody's fine it's great but
you know when things get revealed and it
may take a long time for that to happen
it's I think gonna be tragic it make as
part of this it's like there's a
separation almost from setting the
vision and the ambition on the science
and engineering side and really having
to motivate people right to want to work
on something that's really hard and it
almost seems impossible when you talk
about hey I want to go
to rocket and reel and adorn I want to
build this you know super sexy sports
car on the electric vehicle side that
can actually be a huge benefit in
science and engineering when you'd then
turn to financials it's almost like the
gift on one side is the curse on the
other to some degree yeah I think that's
right
but but I think that there are other
models of people who you know do amazing
things that are worth celebrating I mean
I truly believe that Bezos you know and
he's not without his moral
transgressions and and labor mis
practices and there's lots to curtain
you know nobody is infallible but I
truly think that his his kind of
thinking and building an enterprise he
goes beyond just commerce and pricing it
goes deep into technology I mean he's
somebody that says you know I can't
predict five years out what technology
is gonna matter but I can predict with
very high certainty people are gonna
want more convenience they're gonna want
more choice they're gonna want their
stuff faster they go a lot lower prices
and so all the technology investments
that he makes from robots and automation
to inevitably self-driving cars for
24-hour delivery are just very
systematic and thoughtful and and I find
frankly inspiring now of course he's
going to space also but he's finding it
out of his own pocket from profits and
cash flow that have been generated from
a business that has never raised
equity capital you know since their IPO
in in the case of Amazon so I admire
that much more because I feel like it's
it's rooted in sort of a grounded ethics
and execution that is really rare yeah
and so one of the questions somebody
sent me that I was fantastic was if you
took over a CEO of Tesla what would you
do differently I I would I would hire
Elon but I would put a you know a ream
around him of controls you know one of
the things that's interesting is you can
name a lot of great people at Microsoft
you could name a lot of great people at
Amazon you can name a lot of great
people at Apple it's very difficult for
you to name a lot of people at Tesla and
the turnover has been you know pretty
insane and well-documented but I think I
think Tesla needs Elon to be able to be
a visionary
you know and I wrote this letter which
he saw you know semi famously farted at
write on Twitter which was were on your
board this is what I would do and was
mostly give him the permission to fail
meaning let him restructure get rid of
the debt raised the capital that he
needs
take a breath be honest and and and I
think that would just be a wonderful
reset and and I said you know in that
letter then I would be table pounding Li
long Tesla you know it was such a weird
thing to say so III think it's just
really restore integrity and honesty and
stop the you know the magician show it's
just not necessary yeah it's a super
nuanced view and the the reason why I
think it's so interesting to kind of
hear you talk through this is it's not
like you haven't invested and spent a
lot of time with people who are doing
other really ambitious things in science
and engineering right so every one of
our entrepreneurs right is basically
telling us a story when they come in
right I mean they're telling us
something that doesn't yet exist and
then we have to hold them to task and
accountable how much capitals can
accomplish what on what period of time
and then we put more money in and the
ambitions of what some of these guys are
doing is just you know insane right I
mean we have people that are launching
rockets we have satellites up in space
we've got autonomous systems that are
outed rogue 100-foot waves in the ocean
I mean people doing crazy stuff but most
importantly they're doing it honestly
and the day that they lie to us about
something to try to induce us to part
with our cash is the day that they're
dead to us and so I just think that the
quality of the investor you know
companies get I think Buffett famously
said it that companies get the
shareholders they deserve and when you
have a largely retail investor base over
time I think it says it says something
about the quality of your company so I
want to switch gears for another
possibly show men in another industry
which is Ray Dalio
and kind of the thought process there
where it's less about science and
engineering and it's much more kind of
the let me import my knowledge and I've
got this great you know financial
returns and and we've kind of seen some
similarities both that ended up being
fraudulent and some that actually ended
up being perfectly fine
kind of how do you think through you
know evaluating a situation like that
where there's tons of rumors but nothing
that's necessarily concrete data or
proven and it's unlikely that anyone
will ever see the actual return date or
anything like that until it either is an
issue or it isn't right it's kind of
like we're all guessing until there's
some big event and it's either revealed
but it's what it says it is or it's not
right well look the positive thing here
again is that you know I think there's
1500 plus brilliant people who work
there producing research and I think
that they're all extremely highly
pedigreed really smart people I think
they understand everything that they're
writing about whether it's global macro
of currencies or relationships between
fixed income and a variety of different
asset classes portfolio construction
risk I think they understand all of that
and they publish it brilliantly I think
the vast majority of them if close to
all of them have never seen a P&L are
involved in anything in actual execution
of trades my basic view is it has been a
lever long bond scheme that has
benefited from a generation with a
client of interest rates and I think the
cult of personality and a little bit of
red velvet rope and high minimums
created this and so I think that you
have sort of a McKinsey like front end
and a very questionable back end and you
know people again are free to invest and
if they get great returns then you know
more power to them and people are free
to raise eyebrows and questions Jim
grant came very close you know a year
and a half or so ago
he ended up with a foot fault you know
stepping over the line on a few things
and and they went after him pretty hard
my view generally is when somebody is
criticizing you you know being open
kimono or just you know putting up the
numbers you know generally shuts up the
critics and that's true of Elon it might
be true of Ray I don't know but when you
attack critics you know it's generally a
red flag yeah in fact as part of this is
going back to this idea of like science
not being consensus a lot of what you do
is you're basically finding people who
believe in a vision of
world that is not popular or a lot of
people don't agree with and then you
make an investment and over time that
becomes kind of a consensus view how
much of that do you guys worry about hey
we are getting sold a a vision that just
is impossible right
or is that an understood risk as you're
investing because you're able to
triangulate with a lot of that diligence
process that you went through well you
know the the fringe outlier reject who
has a view that is different from the
consensus to me is like super attractive
right I mean it's it's again going back
to art music it's it's the underdog it's
the person that nobody's really
listening to and we like to say that we
like to believe before others understand
now that doesn't mean unconditionally
you know credulity is a great master
that leads to frog and so you know we're
all washing our hands you know wearing
masks because of a madman or somebody
that was deemed to be a madman in the
1800's in Vienna which was Ignacio Weiss
who said you know I actually think that
when doctors are going from opening and
teaching in a in a rectory with cadavers
and then going and delivering babies
that they're spreading disease and
people are like this guy's insane he was
actually committed to an insane asylum
and was beaten to death by guards
basically because of severe depression
or not yeah so now but but that theory
of Hygiene was correct and we all know
that this part of the germ theory on
being able to wash her hands to stop the
spread of disease was absolutely correct
but you know this guy nearly 200 years
ago hundred fifty years ago you know was
committed to an insane asylum and beaten
to death so we like the outsiders
because when they are right now of
course there's tons of crazy people
right and they're just wrong but if
you're an outsider and you're rejected
by the mainstream and particularly for
mainstream has something to lose that
they're threatened by that's a really
valuable proposition so we're constantly
looking for that now sometimes we've
made bets on people who are a little bit
fringe and they're a little bit out
there and they're just wrong so how do
we protect ourselves from that it's of
course funding to milestones if we fully
fund a company you know then all of our
incentive is to believe that they're
right and not want to lose our money and
that is how you get into situations like
fairness and some of these other frauds
where people never stop to ask a very
simple question does it work so you fund
how much money accomplishes what the
more period of time you turn over the
card you know you ante up again just
like a poker and then you flip the next
card we we like to say that these sort
of two intersecting arrows for us are
the perfect situation one is where you
have a directional arrow of progress
that feels like it's inevitable and
there's lots of examples of this whether
you know you think about lighting that
we went from you know fire on torches to
incandescent bulbs to LEDs we are not
going back to offices with sconces and
torches we're not going from horses to
horse-drawn carriages to cars to
electric vehicles to autonomous vehicles
you know to have horse [ __ ] you know in
the streets again
it's just not gonna happen so there's an
inevitable directional arrow of progress
same thing in computing going from
mechanical spinning drives to
solid-state drives and when you can
identify those secular arrows of
progress that leads to the inevitable it
doesn't tell you who the company is
don't tell you the entrepreneurs it
doesn't tell you the the the specific
person it doesn't tell you there's gonna
be a hundred of them but it leads you in
direction so I like finding those
directional arrows of progress and I can
share one that like I'm obsessed with at
the moment but the other arrow is this
perception of impossibility and that's
not our perception of impossibility if
we believe and everybody else is like
there's no way that that thing will ever
work then it's perfect because what is
basically saying is the market doesn't
believe and whereas you pay a high price
for a cheery consensus you also get a
very great deal when nobody else
believes and so if you take a company
like control labs you know this was
something that to us felt like a
directional arrow of progress where you
had what I call this half-life of
technology intimacy 50 years ago you
interacted with the giant mainframe you
physically went up to it 25 years ago
you had a laptop or a rather a desktop
and you tickled the keys then you touch
the button on the front monitor and you
flip the back you know beige box to turn
it on twelve and a quarter years ago you
had a laptop and you're tickling the
keys and you replace your mouse with a
trackpad six and a half years ago you
know it's your iPhone then three and a
quarter years ago it's your Apple watch
and then air pods with compute and voice
recognition inside and so that
directional error of progress is more
and more information density and access
and it's becoming more invisible and
it's getting more intimate with you so
what's the next logical thing well voice
of course and we have Syrian we have
now and we have Alexa but gesture is the
next thing you know I'm sitting here and
I'm talking I'm wildly just stick you
leading as I speak most of what is
capturing gesture today are
three-dimensional cameras which going
back to a part of our you know the
things we discussed earlier came out of
the video game movement you know with
Microsoft Kinect and and dance dance
revelution and so when when I got
introduced to Reardon who is the founder
of control labs here was a guy that's
building a brain machine interface
without any implantables and it was
gonna detect from the surface of your
skin what the roughly 15 muscles in your
hand innervated by roughly fifteen
thousand neurons were doing and could
detect every single neuron down you know
to what it was being triggered in the
spine and so I was sitting there typing
on a computer and he pushes the laptop
away and I'm still typing in thin air
and and the words are popping up on the
screen and I'm like this is magic
like the Arthur Clarke quote you know
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable magic this was magic
and so I was convinced that I had seen
the future that there was an arrow of
inevitability that the way that we would
be interacting with our computers would
be first by gesture that I would be able
to swipe in free space like Sorcerer's
Apprentice and then soon without even
having to actually make a gesture just
by thinking of moving I could be able to
control my devices well most of the
people we spoke to said oh that's got to
be like twenty years out like there's no
way that'll work and then once you see
that this thing is working you know I've
got information arbitrage I know
something that the rest of the world
doesn't know and they won't know until
we tell them kind of thing is the
perfect setup so you had a VIN evitt
ability with the perception of
impossibility and when those meet its
perfection a lot of investors talk about
you know betting on a product a team a
market and everyone has kind of a
different kind of viewpoint as to what
works but there's definitely a subset of
investors who believe just betting on
the right market even an OK team or
average team will still be successful do
you subscribe to that or are you more
the team regardless of the market if the
right team can end up being successful I
would say that the number one thing that
I've changed my mind over time and I
give total credit to my co-founder and
partner Peter Abear his people I always
thought the primacy of technology which
to me is the interesting thing like can
you do something
or to do something have you invented
something that is like the secret sauce
that has the castle with a moat around
it with you know knives and sharks and
bombs that nobody else can attack is if
you've got this thing everybody else is
like oh it's so not fair they've got
that thing but the thing that I've
learned over you know nearly two decades
now is its people because if you don't
have the thing if it's not working the
people are able to find the thing that
is working they're able to we ban the
word pivot at Lux but pirouette into the
next thing and so Peter was always about
the primacy of the people the two-legged
mammals that we are betting on who are
the ones that really I mean technology
doesn't move itself you need a person to
be able to raise capital convince people
to part with their jobs and join you on
a mission convince their spouses to let
them do that to move across country you
know and start anew to convince
investors to part with their capital to
convince journalists that their their
scarce Inc is is deserve to be spent on
you to convince a big company who's
gonna take a risk on a no name no
reputation startup to to become a
contract at partner I mean that all
comes down to the people yeah it's super
fascinating you guys were very early
obviously to nanotechnology deep tech
whatever going to call it now what do
you think or the next area so that next
generation of investors that are coming
up that are sitting there saying I think
that I know something that the
mainstream doesn't where do you think
they're looking right now well I can
tell you where I think smart people are
moving to because again it's like you
know we all read voraciously and we come
up with interesting ideas when we kick
around our partnership but most of the
time it's somebody coming in and us
being like wow like we never thought
about that so over the past few years we
have definitely seen a big thrust of
really smart people at the intersection
between biotech and computer science
sort of computational bio and so whether
that is modeling in silico and then
being able to produce drugs or design
proteins or shorten a drug discovery
cycle the tools that you have
computationally developed mostly for
other IT purposes reaching into the
biotech realm is just absolutely
accelerating that in a really
interesting way and he turns me on
because you have some proprietary
technologies
and the markets happened to be huge
because if you can repurpose an old drug
more quickly or get something through
FDA trials more quickly or better target
a potential patient you know all that is
really a creative so that one's a little
obvious and it's been done over the past
few years an area that I happen to be
personally obsessed with right now is
and this sort of fits with a broad theme
across luxe as the gap between science
fiction and science fact that keeps
shrinking is the gap between simulation
and reality and so when I look across
our portfolio companies often what
happens is I start to see a pattern
amongst a bunch of companies on the con
you know if you sort of extrapolate
amongst these companies there's some
interesting pattern that has emerged and
the interesting pattern
when I look at a company like mater port
mater port was taking 3d scans cameras
from Microsoft Kinect basically
assembling them into a module doing a
rapid scan of a physical space and then
using software on the back end to stitch
these things together so that you could
basically have a video game you know
doom like walkthrough of three
dimensional space and then extrapolate
into a dollhouse view and it was just
like this beautiful cool thing
okay what's the big deal useful for real
estate static images you know not
dynamic
combine that with unity the gaming
engines that are letting you to render
you know in virtually real-time with
ever higher precision and resolution and
so I am seeing across our companies you
look at zukes and Ava that are doing
autonomous vehicles or solid-state lidar
to be able to look at the environment
and capture with ever higher resolution
what is actually happening you look at
some of our companies that are doing
this inside of bio in biotech to be able
to image inside of a cell on the one
hand the ability to capture reality with
technology and tools is getting better
and better than ever before with higher
resolution higher speed so that is sort
of point number one point number two is
the ability to model and simulate what
you have captured now when you have
these two layers the capture and then
the model and simulate then you have a
computational layer between these two
things that are talking to each other
and this turns me on because it's this
basic idea of consciousness and how we
navigate the daily world you have a
memory prediction framework if I see you
and you wearing a Yankee hat or okay
if I see you and you're always wearing
the Yankee hat or if you know me I'm
always wearing my skull vans when you
see those bands the next time or I see
your Yankee hat the next time and then
you know I didn't see your face if you
look up I'd be like oh that's pomp or
you might be like oh that's Josh you're
making a prediction based on a part of
the whole from the memory if suddenly
you were wearing a Boston Red Sox hat I
would have emotional surprise I'd be
like oh I wasn't expecting that
and so I update my priors in like this
Bayesian inference and so a lot of our
computers in the machines from
autonomous vehicles to sell drones to
drones in the sky to defense systems are
doing that they have the model of the
world based on capture they're making
predictions then they're in interacting
with the world based on sensors and then
constantly iterating between these two
things that feedback between the
hardware of capture the software of
simulation and the compute layer between
them is seeing a flood of really
interesting talent and so there will be
people pulled from experiments that went
into augmented reality and virtual
reality which in a form is that it's
capturing what you see in the real world
putting a layer on top of it making
predictions that will go into all kinds
of new industries that we never
anticipated so that at the moment is
something that I'm really excited about
yeah and goes back to I think a lot of
the AR or initial applications were
thought of as games are kind of
frivolous to some degree right and
obviously you're talking about much more
but people would consider important one
area of biotech that's super interesting
to me is a genetic editing what are you
guys seeing there what kind of work have
you done or found that it's working or
working on so two things that we've done
there's a new code that my partner Adam
Goulburn who's a PhD stem cell biologist
has stood up with one of our our venture
partners in pay conn-young ian was a
founding scientist of a company in the
LOX portfolio called Caleo Bay which is
focused on the gut brain access and he
built an incredible team and then wanted
to go off and start more companies we
said come in house two blocks and do it
with us and so together they started a
company that at the moment is called VNV
it's a virus Mountain virus but the key
thing about CRISPR is there's no
effective mechanism for delivery to a
very specific part of the body
and so what they've done is teamed with
a bunch of scientists who are working on
that
having the vector in part from viral
delivery to be able to deliver to a very
specific organ or cell segment inside
the body so that's one area that I think
is very interesting in genetic
engineering because even if you can
prove that you can use CRISPR or variant
of it in the lab or in petri dishes or
in mice it doesn't really extend to
humans and you're gonna need the
delivery vehicles and vectors to be able
to do that second area which I alluded
to before which again was really
inspired by science fiction is going to
the outlier regions of the world and
trying to find outlier individuals quite
literally mutants people who have very
rare traits so you're not just in this
case looking for the genes you're not
looking at large-scale databases and
trying to find some interesting
statistical you know variant you're
quite looking for the variant in
something that they physically can do so
it might be acute eyesight in very dark
conditions the ability to hold your
breath underwater for long periods of
time people get into an accident and
their bones don't break people whose
hair just grows you know very thick or
long for a long period of time the nails
grow people who never get you know
facial hair people who have very low
cholesterol even though they eat a very
high fat diet people only need one or
two hours of sleep of metabolism people
who have very high oxygen saturation
rates but a very high altitudes like the
Sherpas and so we put together a team in
a company called variant that is focused
on going to these outlier regions
particularly people that are not Pale
Male stale white Europeans so not people
that have been sequenced by 23andme and
from general and Genentech and Roche and
you know they're going to Pakistan
they're going to New Zealand with the
Malory's they're going to Nepal with the
Sherpas all these weird regions to find
these really interesting traits with the
idea that if there's a mono genic
condition meaning a single gene might
make the protein that lead to that trait
then that gene might be a target for a
drug for the masses and that is really
inspiring because it's right out of
Professor axe you know an x-men yeah and
so like on that specific example how do
you go from hey those shippers have
incredible oxygen capabilities that
others can't is it something where
you're actually taking you know DNA
sequencing and
trying to come back to a lab and then
the thought process is how do we now
scale this to to bring two other humans
or is it something where you actually
start with no let's go find people who
have very low oxygen capabilities and
like let's solve health care issues
before we get into things that would be
considered more like nice to have like
almost cosmetic type applications of
genetics yeah well I think the the moral
underpinning is how do you reduce human
suffering and so the by is ought to be
you know how do you take something from
some sort of superhuman and apply it to
people that are suffering inevitably it
will raise moral and ethical questions
about you know people doing genetic
enhancement and people you know doing
the equivalent of genetic doping for
sports and more you know trivial things
if you you know put a moral value on it
so in this case it's it's really a
combination of genetics population
genetics computational genetics looking
at family histories then you're looking
at ethics and partnering with some of
these local communities so the thing
about this particular company that I
really admire is the first two people
were computational geneticists that were
founders they came out of Cold Spring
Harbor and the CEO which is gonna be
announced
pretty imminently has actually come from
the Bill and Melinda Gates Foundation
ran a huge program there and the second
and third person that I hired after that
was a cop it was a cultural ethicist a
cultural anthropologist and an ethicist
so the cultural anthropologist because
when you approach all these different
very diverse populations you have to be
really considered some of them might
care about financial renu Maury ssin
some of them might just want better
health access some of them might want to
be partnered some of them might not want
blood drawn and so there's all kinds of
unique very idiosyncratic situations
that each of these that unique cultural
anthropologists and then the ethicists
to understand what is the right thing to
do here and so many of these indigenous
populations have been exploited over
time that their default the stance when
approached is you know no thank you
so I think these guys want to put the
competitive advantage because of just
the approach of how thoughtful and
considered they aren't approaching all
these indigenous populations yeah and
then something like that like how much
of it is call it simple but that's not
fair to to the team
there hey people in Nepal the nurse does
have high oxygen capabilities most
people would guess that's probably true
versus there's somebody somewhere in the
world who has great eye vision in dark
circumstances and they don't even
realize that that's actually a mutant or
an advantage right they just have grown
up their whole life knowing that they
can see in the dark
right and do you guys have to kind of go
to both types of populations places
where you it's a known fact that hey
there's an advantage this human has over
others and then also do something to
kind of get the serendipity or the
exploration to figure out the unknowns
to some degree yes most of it starts
with the the former of trying to find a
really interesting phenotype where
somebody has advantage but it really is
critical to understand genotype
phenotype and understand whether or
something is because of a monogenic
condition or because of some interaction
between nature and nurture between the
environment and genetics in many cases
it may be that's something that exists
in a particular region you know really
is turned on because of the epigenetics
the gene makes for some proteins that
are expressed because of something in
the environment that doesn't occur you
know if you were to port it somewhere
else I mean you see this kind of thing
for example very naturally sickle-cell
anemia
you know many believe it was a
adaptation to protect against malaria
but when you move people out of a
particular region to a different
continent in this case because of the
atrocities of slavery then you have all
of these people that suffer from
sickle-cell anemia
same kind of thing if you take people
who genetically were adapted to a
particular latitude of the earth and you
move them further north where they're
getting less Sun you know you have you
know higher incidences of vitamin D
deficiencies and all kinds of issues so
the the interaction between you know
biology environment where we are on the
planet the specific geography it's it's
so complex the reason that some of these
quote-unquote Island populations are
interesting when I say Island
populations obviously the immediate
thing that pops into your head is you
know well these people are in like you
know Polynesia or an island but I'm in
Pakistan for example there are island
populations not because of geography but
because of close interrelatedness we're
cousins are marrying cousins you have a
higher probability of a mono genic
condition which is you know single
makes a protein makes the trait and
that's really the needle in the haystack
that you're looking for yeah the the the
best example as you were talking there
about kind of environment is I knew
you're on Eric Weinstein's podcast
recently now listen to the episode with
him and his brother and this whole idea
of like the rats and the telomeres and
actually science had it backwards simply
because of where the rats were coming
from in the environment they were
basically being you know held captive in
until those tests were being done you
know in Eric's I mean Eric's absolutely
right because he is lovingly angry at
his brother for not saying dude like why
are you not pounding the table saying
like I was wrong I was completely
screwed by a Nobel Prize winner who had
the cloud in the status and basically
took an idea that I had and sort of you
know just just hit it and ya know I mean
it has profound implications for nearly
two or three decades of scientific
research
you know we've cured all kinds of things
in mice from cancer to you know
repairing vertebrae to let them walk
again and the kinds of mice that were
walking we're working on or have been
genetically you know engineered almost
inadvertently and I want some skiers and
talk a little bit about crypto just so
people understand like what have you
guys done there if anything and kind of
how or does luxe think about that space
you know in general so two or three of
the partners focus on it a little bit
more intensively we've made probably
five investments including in one fund
which was trading and cryptocurrency is
mostly for sort of information and Intel
block stack is one that is right above
us in New York some of these were bets
on people and philosophy like in the
case of block stack you know me Ben Ali
we we just talk were sort of
intellectually honest they were critical
of a lot of other projects they weren't
sort of part of a hype train we had some
good co investors and we just thought
that the way that they were thinking
about distributed controls and access
was was rational
my general stance has been one of true
believer in the merits of distributed
Ledger's of the mathematics behind it
and much more skeptical of the
particular currencies over time it would
take a inter subjective belief which
Bitcoin
has now become sort of runaway leader
whether it's you know 10 X or 20 X you
know the number two and I think that
that will exacerbate right I mean I
think it'll be sort of a runaway leader
you know for some period of time between
a theorem and ripple three years ago do
two years ago you know I mean anything
when but you know what the killer app is
going to be or how long I I think that
this is one of those things sort of like
you know science proceeds funeral by
funeral I think it's gonna be a
generational thing
I had thought pre kovat that we were
likely to see a twenty20 fall uprising
in an election year driven by Trump
pointing a finger at Powell in the Fed
and basically blaming him for a market
led recession and so I had just
hypothesized speculated with low
probability but high magnitude
consequence that the market would tank
that Trump in an election year would
point the finger at the Fed and
basically people not really
understanding the Fed and what they do
but seeing all of the symbolic markings
of an institution and Washington you
know columns and and and bankers and
banksters we would reignite in Occupy
Wall Street of 2009 but this time
instead of having you know sort of
libertarians on one side wanting low
government and you know anti banksters
you know sort of Seattle who protesters
you know on the other side that you
would basically have the young and the
old the old basically rejecting fiat
currency and going for gold and the
young basically saying no our medium is
going to be crypto and Bitcoin both
would be a rejection of the dollar all
that was pre coded and pre the fiscal
and monetary stimulus of unprecedented
proportions and and I think you know I
still happen to believe at the moment as
a measure of derivative belief that gold
is still the world's sort of you know
protection against
fiat currency being debased which it has
been for a century but there's nothing
that stops that from shifting to a
generational view that
crypto and particularly Bitcoin you know
is is a better alternative so a couple
of things in there one I'm actually have
the same belief that like gold and
Bitcoin are both going to end up doing
well and it's almost like you don't
actually need the inflation happen it's
more of like the fear of the inflation
right people just say hey tons of
printing of course I've got to protect
myself right they kind of run into these
other assets and I definitely agree that
there's this generational divide you
know people talk to kind of the gold
bugs but I mean they literally hate
Bitcoin right there just like that you
guys are all idiots how could you give
up on the 2500 years of gold and also
vice versa
right I mean you know you kind of play
into it from the Bitcoin perspective
with gold being for old people right or
the boomer rocks it's kind of what the
terminology on Twitter how is your
opinion on that stuff changed with kovat
happening and kind of all the Fed action
interest rates going to zero all the
quantitative easing that we've seen has
it been materially change does
accelerate that happening like how are
you thinking about it now so you know in
in dollar terms you've not seen a huge
run in gold and other you know
currencies you have and so as relates to
Bitcoin you know I forget whether it was
a year and a half ago or two years ago
when Korea had banned it and you know
you would have expected this sort of big
thrust into it you would have expected
in Co vid when news of the first phase
or second phase or third phase that
started to approach you know four
trillion dollars that you would have had
this huge buying and you know some
people are saying well you know the
sell-off happened because you had
liquidation and people needed to sell
what they could and this were stopgap
between you know bid and ask in a
relatively still illiquid market meant
that there was a big sell-off you know
that is relatively recovered today it's
at what ten eleven it's actually just
dropped resized by eighty five hundred
but it was that ten a week ago okay so
you know the volatility obviously is a
measure of just belief right I mean and
and you know I I have admired actually a
deep value investor who I think
presented the most cogent argument for
the ownership of crypto and Bitcoin
particularly in opened you know several
hundred million dollar I think mining
operation which was
Marie Stahl of horizon kinetics I mean
this is a star-lord you know value guy
who it rightly in and is in total
resident criticism with me of passive
indexation in equity markets and she's a
variety of vulnerabilities and you know
is put out from the simplistic of well
you know sixteen million millionaires of
everybody own you know one or two
Bitcoin no that's the entire thing to a
more complex you know if the entire
world of fiat currency shifted over you
know what would be the value of a
Bitcoin and so you know I'm generally of
the view that it would be idiotic to say
this is you know a scam the math is real
the logic is real it still depends on
the inter subjective belief and more and
more people you know basically owning it
I think that you're having a growing
number of people particularly of a
wealthy institutional investor class
that say you know whether it's idiot
insurance or whatever why not one
percent or two percent now you know one
percent becomes a pretty big deal you
know as more and more institutions do it
and look to each other and before you
know it that can become a sort of a
foundational basis for widespread
ownership for no other reason than you
know again inter subjective you know I
didn't Phenix so until everybody has you
know some meaningful portion of it yeah
what you're highlighting is almost this
idea of like money is a belief system
right and the thing that I don't know
yet it's like what breaks the belief in
fiat currency if you take the US dollar
for example that is a very very strongly
held belief it's backed by everything
from kind of Full Faith and Credit of
the US government to the military my
global reserve status and there's a lot
that goes into a very complex system for
that currency belief to break it's not
gonna just be you and I wake up and we
read a headline right now a sudden hey
I'm gonna go with all my wealth out of
us to know denominated assets other
currencies obviously we've seen them
kind of fail very rapidly and so I think
that's the one piece of the analysis
where if I understood that better or had
a very strong thesis I'd go put a
hundred percent of my assets right
because you'd say
when this happens everyone's gonna kind
of shift over I believe before everybody
else and therefore when it's consensus
you know I benefit but to me like that
is the one component here and I was
talking to an investor who recently said
it's all relative as well right just as
much as the liquidity injection in the
US is happening internationally you're
getting tons of liquidity injected in
other markets as well could you see a
world where you know the US dollar
actually strengthens all other
currencies either suffer or fail and
those economies or population start to
opt into something like Bitcoin and as
you get a dollar and Bitcoin environment
we're both of those strengthen and like
it's interesting I don't know if that's
actually gonna happen but I do think
that that belief it is a key piece and
what it really does then it says hey it
might not be a technology problem right
like money might not have a true
technology problem it may be a monetary
policy problem and you know that's where
you've got to start to educate people
and understand the benefits of Bitcoin
versus fear all right and and so on top
of that you've got you know coordinated
debasement you have an entire camp of
people that had a ones fringe theory
that is growing steam both interesting
is the more that people criticize it the
more it becomes sort of normalized as
possibility which is mmt that you know
government that you know Princeton's own
currency can't default and can just keep
printing and printing of those debasing
it by any measure the amount of
indebtedness that a country has the best
way out of that indebtedness is to
inflate the debt away basically borrow
you know stealing from savers and
bringing wealth to borrowers and so you
have the MMT camp
you have the gold camp you have the
crypto camp you have international
monetary policy as both a tool and a
weapon you have the US which I believe
is less sovereign stultifying than than
China because I believe that China will
be probably the earliest adoption of
wide spread nationwide digital currency
not to say Bitcoin but I think that they
will do it because they want to surveil
so
is super complicated and I think you
know sort of the reasonable rational
thing now is it's just a very small
allocation but a you know I'm a
speculative basis there what you're
really betting on is again the inter
subjective belief that people will adopt
this now there still debate you know
will we see a deflationary environment
or an inflationary environment the case
for a deflationary environment is you
have mass amount of people that are out
of work you have spending that has gone
down significantly you have you know
technology that if accurately counted in
GDP really would show deflation and
everything except where if things are
highly regulated in you know education
in health care and you know housing
prices and others or you have
inflationary environment where our
supply chains have been constricted our
ability to produce has been hampered
pent-up demand leads to an explosion in
prices people say holy [ __ ] in the same
way that I never you know thought that
toilet paper would be out you know in
the in the grocery store and people were
bartering forward or paying you know
eight dollars a roll or paying twenty
five dollars for you know pack of Lysol
or whatever you could see that that is
all inflation and so if you saw that
happening writ large we've been warned
about or talking about meat shortages
and suddenly you were able to buy a lot
more because Bitcoin for example or gold
was holding its value while the dollar
on a purchasing parity basis was losing
it you know that would be a big shift to
or you know you could sort of see a
crowd like phenomenon of people shifting
but again you know like like you said
there's so many variables it's so hard
it's much easier for me as an investor
to be able to look at an entrepreneur
even though we normally do it in a very
multi dimensional analysis and right now
we're doing it off and in a two
dimensional analysis on a flat screen
void of all of the you know
psychological aspects that you can
Intuit when you're with somebody but
it's much easier for me to look at that
person and look at the technology that
they're building and see truth where it
is independent of what everybody else
believes you know ad infinitum yeah I
mean look I've been very fortunate to
talk to a lot of these these back row
investors who they spend all day
thinking about all that complexity and
somebody asked me what's the number one
debate right now and it is that
deflationary versus inflationary
environment and I think that one
that is determined or there's some
consensus view as to where that's going
kind of all of the other investment
decisions will cascade off of it and by
the way I think I think it will be not
quite as a mirror where as a proxy of
the market but you know whether you
think the market today is cheaper or not
the equity public markets some companies
are rightly being punished I mean
they're being destroyed down 4050
percent and their likelihood of
prospects in the future might be
accurately accounted for the market
itself obviously is free market cap
weighted and so you know that Apple
Google Facebook Amazon etc which are
beneficiaries today may be rightly so
and so you could see the same sort of
thing where certain companies will have
inflationary outcomes and others will
have mass deflationary outcomes and and
it's it's not going to be a universal
you know correlation of one yeah the
other thing is somebody sent me a chart
yesterday that basically denominates the
S&P in Bitcoin and as you would expect
it's basically you know directionally
45-degree angle down into the right and
it's ways things where you know you also
have to balance
that's a cute chart to float around on
Twitter and kind of get all of that
attention but is that something that is
sustainable and how do you think about
that moving forward so I think it's
really interesting the last thing I want
to talk to you about before we finish up
I usually ask everyone whether they
believe in aliens or not so we'll get to
that in a second but you've obviously
done a lot of work on space and a lot of
the science and engineering needed to
both do transportation manufacturing
space travel except for just maybe just
talk a little bit at a high level of how
you think about space exploration where
we are currently in our ambition to do
certain things in space and what you
think may be the next 10 years of space
technology looks like okay so you want
to save the aliens for after or do you
want to include that in here but let's
get to the aliens last because I think
that the technology in space will will
help inform how how you view aliens okay
so so let me let me give you my own
moral prescription which is if I had a
limited set of resources to invest you
know for sort of the world space would
be on the list but I don't know that
to be top five and and this was sort of
the debate that I would have with people
about climate change of global warming
all of which is real I have no debate
about anthropogenic causes of global
warming my quip has always been that
there are more important things to
prioritize that our ten-year problems
that should be solved in the next ten
years versus hundred year problems that
could be solved in 50 years things like
Alzheimer's cancer heart disease where
people today are suffering and deserve
to be you know this is sort of a moral
thrust of invention creativity talent
capital should flow to that first so so
space to me is not one of those top five
things now it's it's inevitable if you
accept what I said before that there's
so much randomness and optionality of
things in the pursuit of one thing that
in the sort of exhaustive it fall off
and you end up being created that I
think you know you have all kinds of
unintended positive effects you know
missions to Mars or beyond you know to
me feel like selfish and izing more ego
driven stuff rather than trying to get
us off the planet I'd rather figure out
ways to you know keep us healthy on the
planet on technologies in space you know
we do have people that are doing
launches we have people that are
launching satellites we have people that
are doing imagery from satellites we
have communication antennas that are
beaming to and from satellites in the
near term we will have constellations of
low-earth orbiting satellites and there
will be a slew of companies that produce
that so you will have SpaceX you will
have some version of one Webb
reincarnated its assets and vision
adopted whether that ends up being by
Intel sad some offshoot of Softbank or
somebody else you will have Facebook and
Google and some of the big primes also
trying to rain down Internet bandwidth
to be able to you know connect the world
so that to me feels very likely
Positioning technologies for the
satellites themselves is something
that's quite interesting so today you
launch something you try to you know do
it at a certain frequency and sequence
but the ability to discreetly position
is very interesting
you saw for the first time a robotic
apparatus actually go and do a refuel
and repair of a satellite so that's
something that I've been personally
obsessed with I think it's a little bit
early in
we've met with a lot of entrepreneurs
and I find it quite interesting where
for example on the ground what they're
doing is saying let me raise some money
to do a computer vision problem to prove
that I can lock on to something that
looks like a particular satellite so
entirely robotic Li you know basically
with a black backdrop at Mirror space
and let me show that I can perform a
function on a physical object whether
that's adjusting a solar tile or
removing a piece of debris and so that
to me is actually very inspiring I think
we will have autonomous systems with
communication systems that are reporting
and both repairing and whatnot in space
of course I think the biggest
opportunity where the most money is
gonna flow is ultimately gonna be in
defense and so quite literally you know
the new space commander for our space
fleet two or three weeks ago was mocking
Iran for launching effectively a webcam
into space but you know anytime you mock
somebody obviously you know strengthens
their resolve you know and just look at
you know Obama and Trump at the you know
press dinner but um III think that uh
when China blew up a weather satellite
years ago to remove it you know it was
not demonstrating that it could blow up
a weather satellite it was demonstrating
that he could blow up anything in space
and so offense and defense and space for
critical systems as we launch more and
more things off the planet off the
surface of this planet I think are gonna
be very critical so so I think a lot of
things are gonna revolve basically
around satellites and robots in space
preparing connecting you know Suites of
satellites and all the sensor payload
packages that are able to image and
communicate back down so anything in
like the manufacturing space that you
guys have seen that you think is
interesting or maybe not even a company
just as you guys think through and I
know there's some people who think
there's certain things around
manufacturing in space that are either
more cost-effective can't be done here
whatever it is no I mean we've looked on
the fringes you know from everything
from like mining to manufacturing and I
think that will be inevitability but I
think it's a really far off period I
mean I think the most important thing
will be finding ways to
capture or generate fuel beyond solar so
you know today probably the most
promising thing would be some sort of
satellite that was a solar battery that
could actually store it turn it from a
solid-state fuel into something that
approximated a liquid fuel or a battery
that could be transported onto a
satellite and basically refuel a repower
you know that would be magical today and
we can't really quite do that so know
that that would be sort of the near-term
practical extent but but ya know there's
gonna be you know tremendous I mean if
you think about all of our assets up
there now they're unmanned and there's
gonna be an insane amount of unmanned
assets that are launched by competitors
you know sovereign competitors corporate
competitors and there will be accidents
and there will be technology intended to
both prevent and police and investigate
those accidents and I think it'll it'll
be a rich economy in space do we get
autonomous space aircraft or do we get
on Thomas cars first and driving on US
highways well technically we have
autonomous space aircraft today if you
count satellites you know in the
gravitational pull of the earth you know
locked in geostationary orbit and then
low-earth orbit you know it's gonna you
know effectively be on on its own
autonomous path but no I'm more
optimistic about autonomy
you know terrestrially I truly believe
that you will see you know in the next
few weeks several big announcements Wemo
will announce you know several billion
dollars made of pretty happened today
but but this week it'll be announced
probably three billion dollars plus for
Wemo you know zukes is a company that we
have significant investment in they will
need to raise a lot of money and their
biggest risk is capital but incredible
technology
Aurora GM crews you know a handful of
others this Tesla is not one that I'm
optimistic on for you know all that they
purport about Robo taxis and autopilot
that to me feels just like a really
misleading grab of people's cash but
that'll get sorted out over time but I'm
absolutely convinced that before we see
Robo taxes we will see 24/7 delivery of
autonomous vehicles we're in the same
way that New York ultimately put in a
bike lane certain parts of the city will
have
right-hand turn lanes right-hand turns
are easier than left-hand turns because
you don't have oncoming traffic that are
basically running a physical world
algorithm the way that our routers run
digital or obit algorithms and shuttling
Goods 24/7 groceries pharmaceuticals
packages you know FedEx deliveries and
you know a place like New York would
would probably be amazing for it
particularly in these times so I think
you'll see that a big OEM partnered with
a big autonomous vehicle company and
somebody like an Amazon doing 24/7
autonomous delivery vehicles with
basically a human to do the last mile
delivery because even though people are
making robots for that it's there's
still too many edge cases that are hard
for a robot to do homogeneously is that
like a two three year thing or is that
more like a ten year thing like what
does that feel like on a timeline basis
I think the technology is there within
the next year I think the rest of it is
gonna be you know policy and economics
so you know if somebody wanted to put
down a billion dollars if New York City
wanted to give a billion dollar
concession I mean most cities are not
gonna be in any financial you know
situation to be able to do something
speculative in long term like that right
now it's it'll be neither politically
popular or or palatable or in some cases
will they actually have the capital do
it but if you had you know billion
dollars from the city and you know a
company that was able to put in billion
dollars two billion dollar city to
create right and turn lanes and
autonomous delivery you know you know do
that now got it aliens believer or
non-believer
well believer in the sense that you know
we watch with our kids you know the
Attenborough
you know planet life series in this and
and what they have been able to capture
a subsurface you know the depths of the
ocean the alien forms of life that
exists there which exist they're there
they're documented are just insane
these bioluminescent you know fish that
you know have a little dongle that
basically captures you know something
that swims by it I mean these are the
strangest things you know that you could
possibly imagine and we've documented
them so in that sense these things are
aliens right I mean by definition they
exist at the subsurface of the sea and
the most harsh living conditions that no
other life was ever believed to to exist
so so the prospect of something existing
in space you know sure
do I think that you know we have Rick
and Morty like aliens you know that no
is there sentient life I have no idea
is it possible sure is improbable yes do
I think that there's no microbes or
microorganisms or things that from the
very basis of chemists chemistry and
chemical life and how life itself is a
fight against entropy you know could
that have evolved through basic physics
and chemistry in some small form yes you
know would I be shocked if there was
some form of sentient energy acquiring
autonomous organism that you know but do
I believe in you know Rick and Morty
three I'd aliens that you know we've
imagined for 100 plus years now
there's I forget the gentleman's name so
I apologize but I think he's a Brazilian
billionaire and his goal if I remember
correctly is to go to the depths of all
of the oceans and he's built basically a
one-man submarine and he's gone I think
he's gone to two of the Indian Ocean and
one other and it's just to me that'd be
fascinating like what did he see right
because he's literally gone where no
other humans gone yeah no I mean and
then you know there was a movie again
Syfy sigh fact right the abyss back in
the day this was just a brilliant movie
but you know James Cameron the Mariana
Trench Bob Ballard you know is doing
deep-sea diving I mean super deep sea
and the stuff that they're discovering
you know is insane and so I find that
there's just so much on this planet on
our surface subsurface in our bodies
that is just this great frontier I mean
quite literally fantastic voyage you
know or inner space you know if you ever
saw either of those two old-school
sci-fi movies that there's a much
greater calling here you know before ad
astra so i hope that we solve
Alzheimer's cancer heart disease you
know and the things of flipping our
planet and the people on it before we
start worrying about you know
intergalactic civilizations for sure
last question for you I know that you
read a lot what is the most important
book that you've ever read it's not your
favorite but the actual most important
well the thing like I'm reframing that
to say what what I want
kids to read I'm gonna give you two or
three in the sort of all the same vein
port Raleigh's Almanac I thought was
just brilliant charlie munger
I think is one of the most rational
people and a true synthesizer and
polymath Renaissance thinker of all
these different disciplines I think you
know it's difficult if you read his
speeches particularly the 94 and 95 USC
speech on worldly wisdom and you come
away with that with not being as a
subscriber to this view of the world you
know I'm like I can't connect with you
you know ii would be a variant of that
which i think is a great compendium
seeking wisdom from darwin to monger
which I think just has a root of great
you know interesting mental models and
and then the other one which played a
huge role in my life in appreciating
psychology was childî nice book on
influence of the psychology of
persuasion and it was really a marketing
book intended as a at least frame as the
defensive guide you know against
predatory marketers but I think it was
adopted by many as an offensive guide
but all the principles from you know
liking scarcity Authority it just it it
was to me the early foray into
behavioral science and our cognitive
biases and I've been very lucky to spend
a lot of time with Danny Kahneman and
the one thing that Danny will tell you
is you can document all these biases and
you can know every one of them but it's
like an illusion you know even though
you know it's an illusion you still see
or still fall for it and so the fal
ability of us as individuals as the
species is is both scary and inspiring I
have a friend who always says people
love magic even though they know it's
not real I love love my awesome listen I
really appreciate it so much time to do
this where are where can we send people
to find you on the internet or
[Music]
well definitely go deluxe you know much
capital Tom and then we've got you know
cool webseries future which we've been
doing where we take you inside some of
the cutting-edge engineers and
scientists and founders a lot of them in
the luxe portfolio showing you
everything from defense to space to sale
your own to bring machine interfaces and
that's on YouTube so I love what you're
doing and thanks for having me man yeah
for sure I
I'll give you guys a big big boost on a
few torah i think you just did the
Enduro one and that's what yet but but I
actually haven't pulled up so link to
that as well and we'll do this again
sometime cool man thanks good to see you